- Hi, I'm after yours.
- Oh my god, I'm after yours!
We should tradesies after the show.
Well, I'm gonna start with-
wait, congratulations, new son, right?
- Yes, thank you very much.
Yeah, six months old.
- [Kelly] Six months.
Oh, are you sleeping?
- Yeah, he's doing okay.
He's sleeping more than we are.
(all laugh)
- So you have a two-year-old, right?
Do you do Halloween?
Do y'all get all done up?
I love Halloween.
- As someone who dresses up for a living,
it's not my favorite
thing to put on a costume,
but of course, my
daughter really wanted us
to do Frozen.
So she's Anna and I am gonna be Elsa,
and my partner's gonna be Kristoff
and so that's fun.
She has no idea that Uncle
Jonathan is Kristoff yet.
That'll be mind-blowing when
she figures that out, but.
- Oh my god, yeah, she would lose it.
But it is funny when-
'cause my kids saw an
animated thing that I did
and they were like, it broke the wall
and it was kind of intensely sad.
Yeah, yeah.
They saw me in this movie
called "Ugly Dolls,"
and they were like, "we don't understand,"
and I was like, "well,
you know, like Elsa,
you know, she's a real person."
and they were like, "what?"
And I was like, "oh my god."
- Oh no.
What have I ruined?
- I felt like a horrible human,
but, you know, it was gonna
happen sooner or later.
- I do that to kids on
a regular basis when-
like, "It's Harry!"
I'm like, "I'm sorry."
They're like, "you're old now!
What happened?"
(all laugh)
- So that was what's so funny.
My daughter was obsessed
with Chris Martin for like-
I mean, years, and she always watched
the "Yellow" video, but he's younger.
It's his first single, and
so whenever she saw him,
she's like, "well, he looks different."
I go, "well, we age, honey."